[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
the spring 2021 season of the saint
louis corporate chess league
kicks off in an unusual way as mike
cummer
attempts to both host and play for one
of the teams
and now your host mike cummer
welcome to the 2021 st louis
corporate chess league spring league
and this is match 105 and will all
culminate at the
final four in the end of the spring
so here we are i am international
arbiter mike hummer
as you see i am actually going to be
playing tonight i will be playing for
the
merits corporation i worked for a
subsidiary of them
back in 1999 quality controlled services
with none other than chess expert
executive director of the st louis chess
club
tony rich unfortunately tony rich will
not be participating for merits tonight
that would have been overboard but here
we go we have
10 teams playing tonight and
they're all playing for these valuable
grand prix points they'll carry over
those grand prix points to see who
makes the final four so we have the
defending champion
enterprise john boyer time boyer
came through big with point three
seconds left
checkmated the board won from edward
jones in the final four in their
armageddon game
to a take home take home the
championship they got their name
on the prestigious chess board
okay who else we got playing tonight so
the defending champion enterprise
they'll play
bear in round number one round number
one will get underway
uh pretty soon here you know 6 15.
wwt worldwide technology will be playing
edward jones
that should be a good match merits my
team that i'm representing tonight
will be playing express scripts
doherty will be playing ascension
and then we have a new team tonight arko
will be making their debut
against umb and we have
breaking news with the dougherty
ascension match unfortunately
ascension could not bring
two players that that they had submitted
and
since there's so many teams and so many
matchups
dougherty just has four points
right off the bat they because it the
way this goes is back to back rounds
we'll play uh one with the uh each color
basically back to back
and that's how you get the points and
if your team wins the match you know
gets more points than your opponent you
get
20 extra grand prix
points so that's how that's how you get
a lot of points
and for each win uh that you get you get
one grand prix point
so lots of points up for grabs and wwt
as nick risco the
the chief td for the corporate chess
league pointed out
they're using edward jones's strategy of
just bringing
the maximum number of players the
maximum number of players
uh is 16 uh tonight edward jones only
brought 10
but we'll see if their strategy holds up
because right in round one will they'll
be playing
right away
so we got about one minute until i'm
going to make the challenge and then
we'll be off
we probably will be following um
a lot of my games emery's games um in
this beginning but hopefully i can win
quick or unfortunately maybe lose quick
but now i'm playing for the team i want
to win i want to win bad
and and then we can go over and then we
can
hop on and see what uh the founder of
the corporate chess league alex corford
is uh is up to
let's see if alex corford is online
oh i guess i should put slash follow
alex corfer
unable to follow alex crawford oh
all right are we ready to challenge
all right i'm going to attempt to
challenge right here
right now so i am so much better than
you
and i will be playing the gentleman
on board 2 from express scripts
all right here goes nothing
i am challenging a warner 621
please accept please or else we won't
have a show
all right well we're waiting for a
warner
try to maybe follow some other players
big matchup so who's the money on
tonight
oh and of course in round two we'll have
the rematch
of the final game in the final four of
last year
enterprise versus edward jones
can edward jones get their revenge
edward jones is of course
uh the winner of the 2018
and 19 event
so good for them
oh do we got a game we got a game
oh please make a move before okay we're
off to the races all right
so d4 d6 okay so i'm gonna just gonna
transpose
into uh hopefully he'll play the the
perk
and um i really like to get a big h4h5
attack and maybe i can maybe i can win
in them
in record time here let's see if i can
win in record time
f3 bishop here
into d2
yeah and when i went to school um in the
90s
i am the 1998 missouri scholastic state
champion
i started i started playing in 1996 as a
sophomore for a bishop to berg
anyhow the the king of
you know the metropolitan area it was
bianni
with uh taught by uh mr bauer
of of the uh board of directors at the
chess club and he would instruct all his
players to play
the park so i'm very aware of how to
play
this uh and i know all how to
try to check match in about 22 moves so
if i had to bet an over under for this
game i say i'm going to win this game
in let's say 31 and a half moves
all right and we got we're nine away
we're nine away
all right here we go here we go can he
win oh well
that kind of foiled my hopes
well forget about the uh that
you know if you bet the uh if you bet
the over
you're looking pretty good here you're
looking pretty good maybe i should have
played
g4 first huh
shucks
let's see if we can follow alex
kurford's game
you are now following alex kurford
okay but it looks like alex kurffer
doesn't have a game let's see if
i am rounder has a game
oh man
i am rounder is part of our team
long time member of the saint louis
chess club
and we will be having a fall league as
well in 2021
just so you know it's too late to join
the spring season but if you want to
join the fall league
you're more than welcome to like i said
we have 10 teams this year so
it's very exciting times so what is this
guy's threat here
i don't know
instead of the fall league we're in
september october november
all culminated at the final four the
week before thanksgiving
i believe might be the 18th but don't
quote me on that it'll be played on
thursday nights as well
all right he took so i take i don't even
know which way i even want to castle
this is not good he should oh
well e4 looks pretty dangerous here
there are there are 70 well there was
going to be 74 participants as we said
ascension has uh
two no shows so so doherty was already
up four
nothing and basically they'll have
they'll have they'll have three games so
gosh they'll have they'll have to get a
lot of points
they'll have to get ascension will have
to go five and a half
out of six in order to win that match
against doherty so they are
up against it queen to b6
interesting okay so he really wants my
guy
i don't want him to have my guy so i
will play rook
to b1 or b3 or c3
rc4
a neat little way to protect the pawn
and now i can't really castle over here
because he'll have a
discovered check i'm in a lot of trouble
here for my team i'm in a lot of trouble
let's see if i am rounder is doing
better than me you are now following
but why aren't the games coming up
that's the
you might not be able to watch
it's possible that i cannot follow his
game i'm gonna i'm gonna get on
just like well no i can't i can't log
into multiple chess like
i guess i could log in as a guest and
follow their games
all right well let's just get on with
the show here um
i'm in a lot of trouble
yeah if this guy plays e4 on me i'm
i'm in a lot of trouble
so okay so okay so he takes i take he
takes i take
and then maybe i'll get a check or
something
oh or he could play rick the d1 and then
trade off the queens if he does all this
nonsense let's try that
and if he doesn't go for it i'll just
play g4 and get on with the show on that
on that note you're watching the
corporate chess league
this is spring
session number one the spring league
all right here we go
i gotta take this guy well however he
takes i'm just pre-moving the take deal
deal when you play on chess.com and uh
pre-move you you do actually get
deducted a tenth of a second
so here's something to keep in mind if
you're watching
now i would never pre-move queen to d4
here because they might take with the
rook and then
then i look like an idiot
that might look like an idiot anyway
so he's threatening to play rook here
and then just win everything
so i will play king to f1
okay i'm out of the pen
but he's got dreams of checkmate coming
up
quick like
if he could somehow if this queen was
protected i'd be
dead
but luckily he does not have a bishop on
a7
or knight on e4 or anything like that
i think i'll be okay i mean i mean this
is his big weakness so
all right we'll play there and hope
for the best maybe bishop to d well
bishop d3 probably wasn't better because
i don't want
his night coming in here so
i don't know who knows
but that's why i should have got castle
you know
should have got castle when i could have
okay so now he pinned my guy oh but he
just
hung his rook oh man oh and so
my 32 my 31 and a half
prediction might be coming true
all right so the over under is back in
effect
but how to check mate this guy in nine
moves
that is the question
and in team events you would never ever
resign
i mean there's just i mean you're
playing for your company you're playing
but yeah that guy was playing so well
he knew what he was doing i mean i i had
grand dreams of checkmating him early
but he stopped it with his
h5 i guess i need really need to play
g4 first but
all right so he's attacking my pawn
all right let's say get off my file
i'm taking the file i'm
taking the file
i guess i can pre-move king takes just
in case
okay so now i need to come up and do
something
i don't want to get forked or anything
though so
whenever you bring a rook or any piece
you know past that halfway line that
center line you better have a
good reason to put them in enemy
territory because look how many
pieces are so close to my rook right now
as knight as king pawn his other rook
i figured he was going to play that but
should i just go ahead and play g4
if he takes i'll play g5 if he takes
he's got
check
if he takes oh and then i've got
well i kind of do want to win in that
seven move span
so g4 let's just play safe let's just
play safe
what a bummer
a win is a win however can get it
plus five we have plus five just the the
rook
nothing like a free rook that's what i
used to like to say
nothing like a free rook very exciting
to win
free rooks oh and actually this
this bishop e2 move is actually really
good because um
if he takes obviously i'll take back
with the bishop and uh you know attack
his queen but now i have dreams of work
here rick there
and maybe i have enough time 27
28 29 30 31.
five moves to do this one two
three four five okay excellent
queen takes g7 checkmate all right
on move 31. you heard it here first
we don't care about that
all right here we go here we go here we
go
i don't even know what he can play
and the corporate chess league is back
to back we will play
one with each color back to back matches
so i will be issuing a rematch
shortly after i say gg which means good
game
maybe he has to play rook to f uh
f8 here that might be his only defense
well he's thinking maybe it's possible
that nick
risco might be uh updating scores
he won i won i did it except
except i did it i won i won
that and less than uh 32 moves just as i
predicted huh
just as i predicted so that
that makes me feel good so if you bet if
you bet against comer
you really should have known what i was
talking about that guy played
well i mean just one mistake one mistake
did him in
and nick risco has not updated the
scores
yet
so i don't know how my teammates are
doing but rest assured
as soon as this game's over we'll we'll
uh
we'll go over some of uh edward jones's
games
they are playing wwt oh
here we go i mean it's a transposition
but this is the comer variation of the
sicilian
you can look it up uh july 98
chess life it's in there and
uh they and i was like what do you think
about this opening
michael j comer st louis missouri
it was ask larry evans it's
and i've got i still got the chest life
i'll bring it in sometime maybe next
week
or not well we will be playing again
uh march 25th uh that will be our second
match
so if i'm hosting that night i'll bring
it in and i'll show you
there is a as larry evans said there is
a one devastating move you can play
as white but
it's very rare that anybody ever finds
it so
so i am mike cummer by the way and this
is the
cover variation of the sicilian
all right so he played a subprime move
let's say
all right your night is now trapped
and now you got to deal with this night
yep well guys there's just so many good
moves here
but let's take the free thing first
and then we'll get on with the checks
and the stuff because if i take this
knight now
he can retreat with bishop d2 and then i
get that let's just get his bishop off
of here
and then we'll go from there
so i don't want to make any predictions
about how long this
this game might go could it be shorter
than the last one i don't know
yeah i mean usually it goes the the
the way the the cummerbury variation of
the sicilian goes it goes
e4 c5 knight f3 knight c6
d4 takes
takes g6
i don't know i'll show it after the game
very very briefly
but this transposes and there's a lot of
cool tricks in there
if they don't know the okay so he's
threatening my
queen
so if i go here check
if i go here check he'll play c3 and
then i can take e4
let's just be really really greedy
because i could just take the knight and
be happy but
i want it all i want it all chuck
because this knight is never he's got no
place to go
so
i don't maybe i should have just taken
it i don't know i want this e pawn
though
i get the e pawn with check and i'm not
gonna take the g pawn actually
if he blacks with the bishop e2
because then he has bishop f3 oh and
that's
that's the game
all right
i wonder if i can have an analysis board
well anyway
it usually goes e4
c5 but that might be the best game of
the
day award nah i i will i will not uh
i will not i will not uh do that
all right can we start following players
no i will i will not give myself the
award
that would be too uh too much
all right let's let's uh let's try to
get some uh
some results i wonder where nick risco
isn't uh
oh nick risco is updating i was on the i
was on round two
so baby swap for team merits has won
both of his games he's our board one i
was playing board two i won
so we have four so now all we need from
one of our
other oh here we go
is uh ooh and uh
wow all we need from i am rounder in
this game
is a draw and we will get the 20
a bonus grand prix points for winning
the match
let's follow um our other
buddy as well
the ceo from color art he he
he he he joined me so we joined a
super team
so merits could have a full roster today
oh and oh
it looked like he's doing great huh and
it looks like oh it looks like he's
doing the exact opposite of great
he's down by 74 points according to the
computer but
that's why you'd play to the bitter end
stalemate could
could happen here it could happen a
stalemate go to that corner buddy
get in the corner yes he's in the corner
he is in the corner yeah and a draw will
clinch us the match victory
that's why you never give up in these uh
team events yes team merits give them
that 20 point
bonus all right and and and
andy and we even got an extra half point
for that so
we're we're at least up to 24 and a half
points
so we could be leading this whole thing
game drawn by stalemate
what a day what a day he just did not
want to lose that pawn
i but who could blame him who could
blame him
and and more to come more to come
and now who else we got let's let's
see what the uh the founder of the
corporate chess league is up to alex
corford
he has won his first game against old
path
they are playing for none other than
wwt so it's edward jones against
wwt as we said wwt trying
edward jones's strategy just kill him
with numbers you know
16 players they brought the maximum so
let's see if the strategy works out
right now it looks like edward jones
four five six seven eight is up an
astounding
eight and a half to a half
on wwt and you would need
ten and a half points in this uh
for this team match to get the the 20
points because there's
10 players for edward jones
then dougherty with all those forfeit
wins they already have the
six points uh
c cell 0603
oh no no i love legos too
even though they're not called legos
does everybody know that they're not
called legos
oh my gosh there's a big controversy big
controversy on the internet
what what they call legos do you know
what the plural of
lego is ben simon lego
nope what is it
blocks
lego blocks
all right enough about legos
all right what else we have going on oh
arco
making their official debut we did have
an exhibition match
uh doing very well against umb
they have four points and all they need
is four and a half
out of the eight to get the uh 20 bonus
grand prix points
and that's where we're playing for these
these grand prix points
they all carry over to the next events
and the the four teams with the highest
grand prix points at
at the end of uh five matches advance to
that final four
and if you're not in that final four you
can't get your name on the championship
board and so two teams well maybe one
two teams could theoretically get their
name on the board one for the spring
session and one for the fall session
yes the the sixth event that would be in
uh
in the second no no the
fourth uh thursday in may we'll be
having
the final four so it works out
all right what else we got going on here
so
alex garfield let's see what's going on
in the game
enough rambling on and on and on okay so
is knight's being attacked so is he
going to move it or does he have some
kind of tactic
oh and his and his bishop is under
attack so
a lot of a lot of things going on for
alex corford here
you definitely have to deal with the
knight takes
e3 threat more than this knight takes
threat
very dangerous very dangerous
do you play rook f3
and that way you can swing this guy over
for a check maybe
let's let's let's predict rick f3 as
alex's guess how did
alex lose all his pieces
so oh so his knight was attacked instead
of just
dealing with the issue he made a threat
that he thought was greater equal than
his own
but then he gets this big night takes
and the computer's not even that
impressed he's like uh you're up yeah
not even by a pawn whatever well
what does the computer say do i dare put
on the evaluation
it looks like oh all right i got the
value bishop to c5
he finds it
this guy couldn't wait to take his name
rick work is attacking the queen
oh big check big check oh
big check and then followed by oh he
missed the big
check oh i'm gonna turn off this
computer that's just
because his thread is still knighted
there
so
i might turn up this evaluation too all
right let's see let's see uh let's see
my teammates uh
let's see how i am rounder is up to
he's up by four points it says oh and
he's got
dreams of queen here then checkmate
all right
he's got a lot more pawns
all right just nope
i mean why wouldn't you threaten
checkmate if you're gonna threaten
checkmate
i mean actually that would have won a
pawn too you play queen here
and then he plays g6 and then
take his pawn oh well
bishop d2 i mean i like attacking stuff
but that's just me
gary also playing for uh merits tonight
oh b6 is looking dangerous kenny can he
find b6 here
oh come on b6 and you should be winning
unless there's something i'm missing
trappist bishop
b6 correct all right mr mindel
playing like 1998 missouri scholastic
state champion
all right and yet don't go anywhere it's
seven o'clock
in about 15 minutes hopefully we're
right on schedule
we will be playing match number two
and boy what a match do we have to set
things off we'll have none
other than the defending
champions the reigning champions
enterprise
versus the two-time
champion of the 18s and the 19s
edward jones and then dougherty
will be playing wwt merits
will be playing umb bear against
ascension
and bear of course will get those uh
those four points for the forfeit wins
and then express scripts against oracle
let's see if arko
how arcco did
arco did win their match it looks like
it looks like umb did not bring somebody
so that means
merits could already have two points
going in
to the final round so that means all
we'll need is four and a half so all one
lead is two and a half so if i can win
my games on board two
just somebody else just needs to get a
draw out of four games so
high hopes for merits to be in one of
those final four slides
if you if you bring only the minimum
which four
is the minimum it is going to i mean you
have to win
those matches to get those 20 bonus
points because
i mean every point you win in the
corporate chess league
goes to the grand prix points so if a
team brings 16
people and go 16-0
plus the was plus the 20 points and you
play back to match
back-to-back matches so you're looking
at 52
points compared to you know merits
which can only uh get 28 at the maximum
so
you get you got to win you got to win if
you want and you to get in that final
four spot or just bring more players you
know
but wwt well we'll see how it shakes out
they did they did get a couple more
points
it looks like w2 of wwt players
uh did not make it tonight
it looks like maybe even three of them
yeah we were supposed to have 74 players
tonight but
but this this year i mean as you'll see
you will be penalized like right off the
bat so
you better be sure that your players are
coming
or else don't put them on the list you
know because
i mean i mean you're right up against it
it looks like they were down six nothing
right off the bat against edward jones
one of the best teams in the league
and that means all edward jones has to
do is get four and a half points
to uh to get you
all right
oh old path did you beat
alex corford with a nifty checkmate here
oh he finally did see the check and now
instead of oh
there's no fork anymore okay so he's
going there
bishop retreats oh he's okay so his
knight was attacking the bishop
and so so he protects now he got
this knight in a pin he threatens
checkmate
and alex attacked the pin piece
but q takes h2 checkmate good games good
game
they split they each got one point
so let's see if uh
it says edward jones now has 14 points
wwt 10 this is not taking in the uh
so wwt even though they did have those
six
extra games that weren't part of this
match against
edward jones so they were able to get
some points so good for them
maybe their strategy is working out even
if you lose
still accumulate some points so that
means edward jones is probably going to
have about
34 points dougherty with
29 arko with 26.
i don't know why nicholas hasn't uh
updated the uh
the merit score i mean that guy got the
stalemate like an hour ago
so we definitely have 24 and a half and
let's see if i am rounder won his game
he did so that means we'll have 25 and a
half
and um
see what mr mendel can do he wasn't able
to get that
that bishop unfortunately
that would have helped a lot
he played my move b6 to trap it
and then he like i attacks
he moved he protected the knight
oh oh so he's attacking the g pawn i see
so he castles now knight h oh
oh man you know i mean just like in that
one game against
uh the founder right yeah you uh attack
the
threaten the checkmate then you might
get a checkmate you know
you really want to play queen takes g2
checkmate
uh-oh his knight's under attack
so he retreats it to a very awkward
square
there's an old saying never play f6 but
in that position i i don't think i even
mind it oh but you're gonna get checked
you're gonna get checked
g5
uh oh
not a good move oh no
his queen can't take back because it's
in a pin
that's going to be all you know if if
you're going to move your rook
to a place you know where it can just
get taken by the night
when you can actually just take the
night in the first place
maybe you might want to just think about
taking
or maybe maybe you could have just gone
all the way back
i don't know it's dangerous but
not whole not high hopes for this one so
hopefully we'll start
in eight minutes
round number two
we got the big matchup enterprise which
we really haven't heard much about
enterprise the defending champion they
have nine points let's
check that out and see what's going
on
let's see what is going on with the
enterprise game
enterprise enterprise what you do what
you do what you do
round one so enterprise played bear
and of course enterprise top heavy with
uh john boyer and uh
mr tim nisham they both scored four
points
moneyballing got a point five big daddy
jazz 64.
shout out uh seven points
and then the bottom two boards both
split so they got
nine points so they'll have 29 points
and that will be their actual score
because they didn't that they bought
six
merits with five and a half and all we
needed was
four and a half so good job merritt so
we'll we'll be
we'll be with 25 and halfway who knows
maybe uh
maybe mr mendel can uh pull something
out of the
head and get a stalemate again or maybe
even win on time look at
look at his opponent's time getting in
that danger zone less than 90 seconds on
the clock
and not the easiest position to win
oh so if please play bishop to here
um is that just almost checkmate now
well you got one move you might as well
play it
oh gosh and then you're gonna get
checked oh man
all the points add up all the points set
up
i went to c8 instead of b8 what i don't
like about that is now you can get
checked oh and that's gonna be this is
gonna
hurt and then he's gonna do the same
thing huh
that pawn can run
you gotta find a way to sacrifice the
bishop for that
pawn and then who knows i mean that's
gonna be
unless this guy can get a
oh that's that's it that's game
now you're not gonna be able to get the
uh the bishop for the pawn
yup you can't win them all you can't
draw them all
it'll be all right hopefully we'll get
this uh
show on the road
this might be the last game of the uh
of round one actually
you're just tuning in this is the
corporate chess league
spring league number one
105 and we'll be playing
match number two which will be back to
backgrounds one with each color
coming up here shortly at seven o'clock
i am representing the merits corporation
how i worked for them with
tony rich tony rich tony richardson got
me two jobs in my life
um i worked for a subsidiary down in uh
kirkwood missouri or sunset hills
missouri
uh quality control services in 1999
and i left on good terms or else i would
not be playing for merits
that's i can tell you um so
i represent merits which is fun and our
art
we we we've got the the match one
victory
versus uh express scripts and we will be
playing
umb in round two but of course
the match that we'll all be talking
about is enterprise against edward jones
the rematch of the final four from last
year
where john boyer in an armageddon match
checkmated v shawl with a rook
with .3 seconds to take home the title
and enterprise got their name on the
board the big board
and that's gonna be it i think that
concludes
the first round what a round it was
and those are should be pretty much
the live scores you can give another
point to
uh express scripts probably maybe
and then of course if you won the match
you get a bonus 20. so that would be
edward jones authority enterprise
arko and merits
those are the five teams and that just
bumped up
you know this we got a hundred more
points in this uh
grand grand prix just like that
so and those are the teams that are
splitting up those hundred points
you might ask well dude wwt you've got
11 and a half how did they
not get their 20. well they bought a lot
of players and they played extra games
against
other extra players and for every time
they won
they accumulated another grand prix
point so
um
you must take a very quick break so i
can jump on the uh
google meet and make sure that i can
issue a challenge
and then we'll be right back off to the
races coming up here shortly
well i'm alex kirford i'm the founder of
the corporate chess league
financial advisor and captain of team
edward jones
so the whole concept of the corporate
chess league
was an opportunity to bring together
companies
individuals in a way that could be
competitive
it could be fun and be able to
better engage with some of your
colleagues and so prior to the pandemic
in covet 19 we were able to gather here
in the chess club meet face to face and
have games on a quarterly basis
it was a lot of fun had a high level of
engagement
and people beginning to be attracted to
that edward jones has been thrilled
to be to help found but also to
participate in the corporate chess
league
and this year actually it's been a
little bit of a change now that we've
gone virtual
our audience has grown we absolutely
love the corporate chess league i can
tell you
my teammates and i we feel like we're
truly a team and we practice
we have regular practices and we take it
seriously it
has really expanded and the engagement
to want to play
even more has happened during this time
so we took
quarterly meetings to now being able to
put on the corporate chess league
once a month here at edward jones we
actually have
people all over north america about 50
000 close to
associates all over north america i have
a really good friend in the phoenix area
who's passionate about chess
it's hard for him to fly out just to
play into a tournament so now that it's
been virtual
he's been participating on the team as
well so in order to capture the essence
of the purpose of the corporate chess
league
we've been able to provide an experience
where
prior to the competition of chess
actually begins
people are able to come into our google
hangouts page
and be able to see and interact with
each other
in a virtual way and then partnering
with chess.com we're able to provide
the the actual tournament and and how
the competition begins
and the corporate chess league allows us
as a team a to bond
and we're doing really well as a team
i'm happy to say and b it allows us to
kind of
you know uh rib each other a little bit
and and it is a little friendly banter
which we love
and all during that time the st louis
chess club is hosting
a youtube channel that has commentary
from
guest speakers grand masters
international masters
commentating on how the games are
actually going that makes for
a lot of fun for people to be able to
see
how their friends how their colleagues
are doing
all right welcome back round two
is underway i am playing
none other than the gentleman
from umb walt
gather uh oh he's attacking my
pawn i don't see this every day
i'm going to try to win that night right
off the bat
there were playing and they keep saying
hey your game's gonna auto abort
it's like dude i'm thinking i'm thinking
okay
it's like they only give you one minute
then for for your second move
i don't like that i don't like that
all right so this is uh merits versus
umb
uh-oh got to pay attention to what i'm
doing i almost dropped that pawn but my
bishop is protecting it
so with this knight kind of out there
it's kind of got got me out of my
comfort zone here so
could be all right
it could be a okay
it could be a okay all right so the
knight is attacking the pawn so i will
protect the pawn
sound good to everybody
sounds good to me sounds good to me
unfortunately
i don't think we can uh follow
all right he's attacking my knight is in
an absolute pin
so i have to get out of it oh and he's
threatening to play knight takes pawn
i think kind of like in that game i
played i won with
that opening i think this guy actually
knows this opening
so all right so
bishop the d2 bishop d2 is a move you
really
don't want to play it when you're
playing with the white pieces because
it's kind of
kind of passive
okay so he's attacking my pawn
i might just say the heck of it and take
it
okay so i do have i do have
i could put them to the test here
i could play some hope chess love hope
chess
so if i play knight to b5 here
would that accomplish anything i
don't think knight to b5 would
accomplish
anything but you never know
but i know
let's not play for tricks
what if i played b4 well then he would
just take with the bishop
so he's threatening knight takes pawn
i'll challenge your night for my night
round two is underway
in the corporate chess league and we
will be having this
two weeks from now they'll be played on
uh
the second thursday
in march and the fourth thursday in
march
april may and all culminate
at the final four in the in the fourth
week of may
maybe merits can get into it
oh look at doherty with 17 points
they're leading the way dougherty
brought nine people today i believe
so the more people you bring the more
points you can probably get
so those standings are not official by
the way because
five of those teams actually have 20
points which includes
doherty edward jones
bear are going merits
so really really those
those standings really don't represent
what's really going on
in the world
but that's the best we got so far
all right what is going on he played
bishop b4 and i'm just sitting there
like an idiot huh
i want to get castled right
maybe i'll just take
i don't see anything wrong with taking
as long as i don't get checkmated or
something
and now i deliver the check
you love the check you just love it
you love it check
oh or we could play e5
first and then check does that sound
like more fun
like unclip the mic anyway
everything fine i don't want to play e5
by the way because uh
queen takes e5 check makes me look like
a loser
so give him the check first and whatever
he puts on a
d7 i'll take well if he puts a knight on
d7
i probably won't take
uh it took me four minutes to play 11
move well well i'll play this
this move so fast but that's not a good
pace in a game in ten no delay no
increment match
oh my gosh so he did he did do it with
the knight
i know he thinks he's being funny but i
think
i'm going to get the last laugh if if he
plays bishop takes knight
ah he didn't all right nope
that night's kind of obnoxious huh
all right so i'll attack his bishop and
this will be the moment
of truth
please take if he takes i'm definitely
winning
oh now i can play b4 right
b4 what are you going to play if you
play
b4 you have any kind of tactic or
anything
you get two pawns for a piece so
actually while you're doing that i can
actually probably
get the uh the real scores going
anybody want to know what the real
scores are
oh actually i can't even count i can't
even count
all right where's this night gonna go i
have
dreams of oh yeah dreams are just
hanging the night
great um
let's see if i can win a pawn by playing
that move
i think i actually i have to play with
this rook
or wait a minute if i play with this
rook
oh then you can play queen to here
if i don't start moving i'm just going
to lose i mean this is ridiculous
all right i got some ideas i got some
ideas and i do not want to get
backroad checkmated so h3 is coming up
pretty soon if he plays queen to here
i'm just gonna
bust this out like like right away like
right away
no so he he didn't go as far as i
thought he was going to go
all right you got to take this guy
you got to take them so take them all
right well what what are you playing
like right
i got i gotta start start getting
because now he's gonna play bishop to
there
and then it's gonna be very risky to
take this pawn on a7
i got to make sure i don't get back row
checkmate if i get backward checkmated
on the stream
i might not ever do it again
that's why you gotta read that bobby
fisher teaches chess
it stops you from ever being backroad
checkmated again in your life
okay so he played that way
uh michael all right let's just play and
and hope we don't get back real
checkmated
or do i play with the other rook oh
let's play with this rook
get on with the show huh get on with the
show do not get back real check made it
okay
deal deal
and now i'm threatening the background
checkmate
all right i'm plus three now i'm plus
three
okay i almost want to just take that
guy okay let's get rid of all this
nonsense with the back row checkmate
okay
okay
all right the nonsense
is over just because you make that
it's called luft l-u-f-t just because
you make that doesn't necessarily mean
you're not going to get back
checkmated by the way so
but it significantly reduces your
chances
i got three minutes okay he's attacking
my bishop
and my bishop really has no good place
to go
and so i'll get somebody else involved
oh and my pawn is protected by the uh
by the queen interesting oh
and now i got bishop to uh
bishop to b4
very exciting very exciting
all right things are looking up for me
even though i got less than three
minutes to go
it took me seven minutes to make 22
moves
oh no
i guess i'll just play this anyway
oh yeah because now i got the check
oh but he's got the check he's still he
wants that back row checkmate no matter
what
but this is not going to be backroad
checkmate
because because he's got this pawn right
here
if it was on e6 i'd be out of luck
so he's gotta play the check
oh if he plays queen to g6 i'll win it
right off the bat
he plays queen to e6 oh that's gonna be
game buddy i said he was playing so
well the family fork
oh and and
worse comes the worse here i i think i
got it's it's
the worst is yet to come
oh man i wonder if i missed checkmate
oh well
still a lot of work to do here
plus 13 and threatening
oh he got his check and he got his check
luckily it was a okay
so if he plays bishop to e6
i can just play knight takes anyway
right
or maybe rook takes us even more forcing
all right this should be checkmate
yay he won rematch
rematch requested
all right so win one for the home
team for merits let's see if uh any of
my other
teammates go we gotta we gotta watch out
before our game gets aborted we have to
play
two moves before we get or else they'll
be like we're going to abort you
abort the game
they really don't want this game to take
place hopefully we
get to see another comer variation in
the sicilian
oh it was not meant to be so
i know this game so this is my strategy
when they play this e4 c4 stuff
what i try to do is i get rid of that
guy
get rid of that guy and get rid of that
guy
for this guy this guy
and this guy and then i'm just gonna put
my knight right there
and i'm gonna win the game all right
knight to a3 this
guy likes to bring his knights out real
crazy in the opening
and that really got me in a lot of time
trouble last time if he really wants to
go to a6 i'll just say
be my guest
all right let's just check out what if
if
we got some scores in for round two
doherty up six to two on wwt
enterprise
lost on the last board
i am rounder with art with merits
got the automatic two points
bear got six points six to one against
ascension
express scripts got a point over arco
so not too many uh games in the books
yet
oh but look at that the scoreboard is
now
uh getting a little more accurate
edward jones has 37 and a half points
i guess is this guy just going to play
rook to b1 here
i'm attacking his pawn
maybe i should have played that i don't
know
yeah maybe i do have to play my uh my
pawn out first
castle if he plays bishop to b2
my gosh am i messing this up am i
missing like a queen to
a whatever check
i don't think so
you forced the queen's trade off if i
really wanted to
i think i might play a weird night move
here because how is he going to protect
that pawn
oh maybe with queen to d2
now let's just give him a check and see
if he can stand the pressure
oh
can he stand the pressure
oh make sure this isn't a trick
all right well if he tricks me you know
you got it because i guess he's going to
play b4 here
maybe followed by rook to b3 but
in my eyes uh oh this guy is falling
apart
do i even want to play knight takes pawn
it looks
it looks tempting
you know what let's just
let's just say queen you did a great job
and
what about queen to b2
there let's try queen to b2 it's
probably not the best move but
who knows not
me and then my knight takes pawn is a
a valid threat
maybe probably not because then he's got
work to be
one and i'm looking like a
i'm not looking too good
edward jones 40 and a half points
all right you want the queen trade i
want the queen trade let's do it
i just want to get rid of all my pieces
as fast as i can
for his pieces obviously not just giving
them away
and then i got plus three and then all
we'll need is a half
point from our board one
maybe swap our
our other ringer gary mindel
66 the ceo of color art
okay so he does not want to trade i
understand i understand
oh man we are battling with
enterprise arko i don't know if we'll be
able to catch dougherty doherty is
playing
in round two dority is playing wwt
oh and they got a lot of forfeit wins
that's probably how they amassed all
those points right off the bat
okay so now you want to trade night for
night deal check
oh yeah check and then we'll play this
and then we get all our pieces traded
look at that
all right now the bishops are gone
yep i mean chess chest as simple
sometimes if uh
if you have more pieces than your
opponent i mean all you have to do is
then just
trade them off and life is good um
thinking about playing knight here
followed by bishop to there
i don't know when in doubt always push
aside pawn
always
maybe i should have played a5 i don't
know
nobody knows nobody knows
all right what else is going on here
bear does have six points in that
ascension match
so if they have six points
it looks like yeah it looks like they
they got the the bonus 20.
okay so they did they did play that f4 i
kind of
figured he would
once again i mean i'm playing so slow
there's
real no direct path to victory i mean
it's inevitable but
i don't see a way
so he played b3 instead of that
i need to open some files for my rooks
and pick up the pace too i mean i've got
less than half my time and i've not even
moved 20.
not good not good not good oh we do have
we do have some great news at the chess
club by the way
we have opened up our tournament hall we
are allowing 10 players
so check it out we'll have tournaments
all weekend
the quads the saturday night main event
and who knows we might even have a g30
tournament this sunday from noon to five
who knows who knows i don't know
but i'm hoping
all right let's see what's going on here
let's see what's going on
he might actually win this pawn because
i
played silliness
and i have nobody to blame but myself
but maybe i'll get a pawn for a problem
but then he's gonna get this pawn oh my
maybe i gave this guy too much counter
play by trying to get my pieces open but
he got the game uh got the game going at
least
yeah we'll see
all right here goes nothing here goes
nothing
actually i guess he should play rook
i guess i should have played that move
first okay good okay so he takes
i take and now we're moving the game
along
which is good although i don't know how
i'm gonna protect that pawn
that paul might just be a goner
oh but
i'll take it i'll take it
and i'll take this guy
i do not know how to mate with a bishop
and a knight so if he can manage to get
all my pawns off the board and trade the
rooks
it's going to be another embarrassment
and it's going to be another
uh what do i want to do what do i want
to do i could give them a check
well i can't give them a check actually
i could i could attack his rook he moves
then i give him the check
do all these checks do anything
and we'll see we'll see this is a this
is a
this is this is something where you
would never want to trade this rook for
you
the bishop and the knight even though
you're beginning five points for six
you're
basically just be handing me the game
okay and so okay so he protects his
pastor okay
so now let's give him the check that
we've been talking about
and see if it does anything
i am not very good at calculating
just like the give them a check and see
what happens
oh okay
i don't i don't i don't even want to
give them that check
oh my night is under attack my knight is
undred
well this really did not work out like i
wanted it to
it didn't work out at all
it didn't work out at all
all right now i'm in check but that's a
i i like that check
i like that check my king needs to get
get in this game
maybe he can run up to h3 and then i can
deliver the checkmate with the rook
everybody cool with that plan everybody
yeah i figured he was gonna play that
move
i like it i like it attack the rook
well now this rook has to move
and now my king's going up he's going
places
so one two three four five six seven
eight
all right i'm cool with that i'm cool
with that oh actually i'm really cool
with that
bishops can move backwards it's a big
secret in chess
big secret now we do not want to be
given
the stalemates everybody got that
you know in fact
you want to just stick with the the old
plan
all right so we've determined that he
can always go to g
one
and this is where you don't wanna get
fancy and do anything
silly you just want that a direct way to
get
checkmate
like oh i want to checkmate him with
tonight and show how cool i am now
you can just get see the checkmate play
the checkmate
yay all right team merits on the board
and now we can follow the other games
progress the big match the match
of the day enterprise against
edward jones see what's going on
now i guess i got to go back is there
any way i can
get out of here
right
so it looks like mr mendel ran out of
time
in his game
moneyball and beat alex curfer tonight
2-0
that is a shocker
all right see what else we got going on
a lot of games have concluded let's go
read some scores of
v shall be let's let's get that game
going
the the big rematch of uh the armageddon
match
v shawl against
kamikaze knight john boyer time boya
all right here we go oh
can john boyer pull off some heroics
with 0.3 seconds again of
what is going on it looks like they're
saying somebody's got
mate in three
and nobody's time is moving oh okay
there goes
john's time john is kamikaze nice
playing
and somebody has made in three who it is
who knows who has mate
in three here if i had to guess i would
guess the black pieces
all right there's check
so now king takes rook
queen takes bishop
rook to over there and now rook back row
checkmate
good job johnny b
so let's let's check out so okay so that
is
that score is 1-1
mr tim nisham has lost
his first game against jd
let's uh
let's follow chess hulky
mr tim nisham
and let's see what they're saying about
this one they are liking tim neesham's
position
so if that one is one to one moneyball
and got the
got the shocking victories he got two
wins against
alex kurford big daddy jazz 66
lost to one of our favorites in the
corporate chess league king taker one
three two
four so king taker got that one
on their next board uh edward jones came
up big
and then and then they won again on the
final board so they have three four
five six so right now the score is six
to three edward jones
and right all you need is six and a half
so
to to win this match so
so basically if enterprise
gives up one more half point they are
out of luck
so basically right now all they are
doing is playing for a draw
with edward jones and then they would
split the 20
bonus points and each would get 10.
other highlights doherty two
four six eight
eight points against wwt but wwt
four five six seven so that one is uh
hotly contested merits
it's official we sweep
we sweep umb
did our ringer on board four come up big
oh i got a pin gary mendel
uh oh this is oh he's threatening
maybe a oh bishop check maybe or
bishop check is looking good to me
no
oh did he miss a shot here
because if you play check oh
well this is the position okay this is
where i want the guy to play
check yeah bishop takes f6
check best move on the board and the
only move that actually gave
uh the advantage to jd but he missed it
it was not meant to be
all edward jones needs is one more half
point to
to get their uh big revenge on the
reigning champions of the corporate
chess league
enterprise
we will be giving out some sort of uh
prize i guess tonight
maybe what do you say ben simon
some sort of prize
but i think your only prize is pride
i'm not in charge of it either
oh all right i got one more trick up my
sleeve to see if
mr gary mendel actually went 2-0 to
complete the sweep
for merits here
all right
oh
oh it was another forfeit victory
an absolute bummer too many forfeit
victories going around tonight
we don't like the forfeit victories
let's get back to a game here
if i can
all right the tide has turned
it looks like mr tim neesham is
doing his best to keep enterprise alive
but let's see if if they really are
still alive
edward jones has two
three five seven
they came up big on the uh lower boards
and um so edward jones has defeated
enterprise so give edward jones another
20 points
and most likely another uh
match well not match victory but uh
what would you even call what what is it
round one of uh
spring league match one of five yeah so
so you win a whole other uh
match obviously you don't get any extra
points in the standings for finishing
number one but
it's a great way to start the 2021
spring season campaign
hey mike yes sir ryan said that the
reinchester club manager said
the winner of the game award
gets a free grand master lesson oh
interesting
all right free grandmaster lesson
i know who i'm going to give it to even
though
it may not have been the the game of the
year but i know who i'm giving it to
and maybe i am a little biased because
um
because i was playing for team merits so
so maybe i shouldn't even be able to
to give oh i could give it to uh
myself for my big uh well i called it
that i was gonna win in less than 32
moves and i did
and then i got the big karma variation
hopefully
oh this is coming down to the wire here
is this this could be anybody's game
here
he's got made in four can he see it
now it looks like the other guys got
made in seven
i don't know what's going on all i know
is uh it looks like tim neesham's gonna
run out of time
so jd with edward jones
cements the victory and that's probably
going to do it
for uh for the for the whole match
for edward jones and i think that is uh
the conclusion of the uh of the round
so edward jones defeats enterprise
four five six
eight eight to
three that can't be right
three fours eight to four
eight to four edward jones wins eight to
four
doherty let's see how many points they
got they got four
six eight seven
and wwt got two
four six seven nine
wwt wins nine
to seven does that make sense
four six eight no it does not make sense
all right we got one more big score for
uh
doherty dougherty actually finished with
nine points
wwt finished with nine points
so that was a tie so they split the
the grand prix bonus 20 points
okay merits
led by maybe swap and board two
uh michael jake homer swept
umb eight nothing to accumulate
as 28 points in that
and then bear
defeated ascension 7-3
express scripts
seven points to arko's one and then some
extra scorers got it all added up
so let's take a look at the final final
standings
edward jones which part 10 players
got 67 and a half points to win the
overall competition tonight
merits came up big with two
count them up two ringers to get 53 and
a half points
dougherty right behind with 50.
wwt didn't win a match
did not win a match
lost in round one to edward jones and
then a draw in round two
but because they brought the maximum
number of players 16
they still amassed 38 points
and are now in a final four position
great strategy mr rock harris maybe i'll
give him the uh
the coach of the year award all right
express scripts right behind with 37 and
a half
bear and enterprise 33
arko in their debut gotta got a nice
victory over umb
to finish with 28 points and
unfortunately ascension and umb
both had a lot of forfeits
and so they didn't they didn't come up
too big
this week but there's still four more
chances this year
uh to get into that final four
and um
and the next one's just two weeks away
march
25th mark your calendar maybe i'll be
here
maybe i won't be maybe i'll bring in my
chest life
where i debut the comer variation and
let's get to the uh
um you want to take a very quick break
and then we can
we can just announce the winner we don't
need to see it
it's uh it's the big stalemate that
clinched the match for merits
gary mendel 66 he knew
he knew he didn't he knew not to give up
he ran straight to the corner
and achieved a stale mate and that gave
us
it gave merits the the the clinching
match
in round one and propelled us to number
two in the standings so
congratulations to uh the ceo of color
gary mendel
and i will be getting in touch and and
getting
a grand master lesson scheduled with him
all right
so take care everybody it was a blast
good night
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st louis chess club
you